hey youtubers is Charlie so this is
gonna be my Walking Dead Season 6
predictions video since we've started to
move more into comic book moments like
this order to adapt the comics more this
is just like a mixture of stuff from the
comics and stuff that they've already
changed I do think that they will do
more stuff from the comics but just like
we saw in season 5 when we do see stuff
from the comics it'll be slightly
changed just to fit with what they've
already changed like certain characters
from the comics are already dead on the
show and vice versa so whenever the show
does do a comic book storyline like
Alexandria safe zone they have to swap
some of the characters just based on
changes they've already made I'm also
doing any round of the giveaways all you
have to do to enter is be subscriber and
leave a comment on this video real
simple since I'm not doing a Q&A I'll
just I'll now who the winner is whenever
I post my next Walking Dead video so I
know everyone's wondering about
characters getting maimed who's gonna
die next like what we're gonna see from
the comics so I tried to work all that
stuff into my season six predictions
here we go just careful for spoilers for
everything through season five of the
show and the stuff from the comics that
they've already done on screen I kind of
did this in chronological order starting
with number 10 the Wolves will bring
their 18-wheelers to the Alexandria safe
zone it's no coincidence that the wolves
were looking at pictures of Carl Ric and
all the other people to save so I know a
lot of you were wondering how they got
those those were in Aaron's bag remember
they got caught in that trap and tried
to escape and dropped a bunch of their
stuff so that's how I think the bag with
the pictures got left there I know
there's also a lot of questions about
how many wolves there are because it
seems like there were three and then
they killed red poncho guy here so as of
right now let's just say there's two but
we could see more appear in the premiere
what I'm really hoping for is that we
see like a red poncho Walker be like one
of the first ones out of the 18-wheelers
whenever they roll up onto number nine
season 6 episode 1 won't be a carbon
copy of season 5 episode 1 with terminus
rewind to the beginning of the year if
you remember the survivors effectively
destroyed terminus with the help of
Rambo Carroll I do think they'll
eventually leave the save zone like
eventually we'll see other places
they'll travel around but the safe zone
is way more fortified than terminus and
based on the changes that Rick is trying
to make they're gonna be more prepared
for threats that means that we have no
idea what the timeline is going to be
between the finale and episode 1 of
season 6 I think it'll be a relatively
small timeframe that means the price
be fairly unprepared whenever the Wolves
get there so [ __ ] will go down but what
I'm hoping is is that it Morgan like
once he reunites with brick tells him
about the crazy people that he Darrel
and Aaron ran into like oh we went to
this crazy place we thought there was
gonna be a bunch of food there surprise
surprise 18-wheelers full of walkers so
they might be aware of the wolves and
start to make some adjustments based on
that but it doesn't feel like there's
gonna be like a month in between them
finding out about the wolves and the
wolves arriving it'll be like really
quick moving on to number eight losing
Diana's husband the engineer and dr.
Pete is gonna cause huge problems
Deanna's husband is the one that built
the walls the metal walls and kind of
handled their infrastructure like other
utilities water power all the really
important stuff that you need to live
but you take for granted they tease that
Noah was going to apprentice to him but
then of course both those characters
died before the end of the season so
someone's gonna have to pick up that
slack then we have dr. Pete the only
skilled surgeon in the area that they
knew about that means that more people
will probably die from injuries that
could have been treated had Pete
survived yes getting rid of him was a
good thing but it's gonna have some
severe consequences like the next best
surgeon that we've seen on the show is
Michonne with her katana if they're
getting ready to be assaulted by 18
wheelers full of walkers they're going
to need as many medically trained people
as possible so whatever ends up
happening to the safe zone in the
premiere a bunch of red shirts are plug
an end up dying moving on to number
seven
Morgan will join the group in a
semi-permanent way I don't know how long
he'll stick around for but as of right
now Lenny James doesn't have any other
like major commitments on his IMDB page
hopefully he'll stick around for a while
he does have his own comic book plot but
but I do think that they'll end up
weaving some other characters stories
into his just based on the way they've
changed the character he's got like this
Zen ninja thing going on and there's
some other characters in the comics that
have that so they might graft some other
characters onto his character so don't
expect his story to go completely the
way it does in the comics really I don't
think that Morgan's story with the group
will end until like he and Rick balance
each other out a little bit because
they're both like opposite ends of the
spectrum right now Rick is kind of crazy
Morgan super Zen so I think you know
somehow they'll mellow each other out
just a little bit that means Morgan
realizing that it's okay to kill some
people and Rick just getting a little
bit less
our core moving on to number six new
locations so I think the show is gonna
do a version of hilltop just to avoid
you know rampant comic book spoilers I
want to talk about what goes on in
hilltop let's just say it's like the
next big location or one of the next
couple of big locations the show stayed
pretty true to the safe zone in the
comics I'd like they called it the safe
zone so if we see like other big
communities of people they could do the
same thing or they might just like
change the name a little bit like they
did with Wiltshire estates what pluggin
end up happening is is this big Walker
attack they've teased from the Wolves
will go down the survivors will beat
them off but it'd be like a huge drain
on their resources and because they
don't have an engineer they don't have a
doctor they're gonna need to find help
somewhere more food more skilled
technicians that means Daryl Aaron other
people roaming around looking for other
people to help out which is where I
think we'll arrive at Hilltop and just
to be clear even though Scott Gimple has
a history of destroying new places you
know within like a couple episodes of
the survivors getting there
I think they'll spend longer at the safe
zone I think it's in terms of duration I
think it'll be more like a prison stay
so it won't be like multiple seasons
like they'll leave the safe zone before
season 7 but I do think it will continue
to exist throughout season 6 what we'll
see though is just like side episodes
with individual characters like going
off on their own for like a whole hour
so like Daryl and Aaron go to another
community Rick goes somewhere else so
you don't have to burn the safe zone to
the ground right away just to give the
characters a reason to move around I
think a lot of like the moving around is
just an answer to the season two
complaints that they stayed at Hershel's
farm way too long
Glen Mazzara also kept Woodbury alive
for almost like a whole season I think
it appeared for the first time in
episode 3 and they didn't like leave it
for good till the finale so the governor
like mode everyone down with the machine
gun whenever Scott Gimple took over he
made quick work of the prison then
terminus then the hospital I mean they
didn't burn the hospital to the ground
the survivors just took off so even
though I think that they'll break the
safe zone a little bit I don't think
they'll completely leave it moving on to
number 5 talking about new characters I
think that we're going to see a version
of Paul Monroe I've seen a lot of you
guys wondering if Morgan's gonna get all
the hey Seuss stuff from the comics just
because they share some attributes but
there are a lot of things that are very
different about Morgan's
character I don't think they could
completely get rid of hey soos
especially they're gonna do hilltop just
because I don't wanna get too crazy with
comic book spoilers here's a timeline
for where to start reading in the comics
which you should do that last scene in
the finale is really similar to the last
scene in volume 13 too far gone so let's
just say season 5 ends with the end of
volume 13 so I'd recommend you start
reading with volume 14 no way out
season 5 actually cover quite a bit of
stuff like they started with the fear of
the hunters volume 11 and then went all
the way through volume 13 I don't know
necessarily that they'll cover that much
territory in the comics in season 6 but
it's totally possible the problem is is
that by moving that fast they they bump
into the Savior's and negan really
quickly and I don't think the show is
ready to do them right away in season 6
which actually leads it to my number 4
once we do see hilltop or a version of
hilltop in the comics we'll start to see
the Savior's they're like two things
that kind of go hand in hand
and think about the way they introduced
the wolves because I think it'll be kind
of a similar situation first we started
seeing Debbie's carved into everyone's
foreheads then we started seeing
graffiti like in Wiltshire Estates
then we saw a fresh body and then and
then with a little bit of help from
Morgan we finally met one of the wolves
the Savior's are kind of like a bigger
more well-equipped more organized group
of wolves like we might start hearing
about a group terrorizing surrounding
communities extorting supplies from
people then we'll see some physical
evidence of their presence and then
eventually we'll meet one or two of the
Savior's I just I think it'd be a better
reveal if we met Savior's before we met
negan like he's not just gonna walk up
and say oh hey I am the biggest villain
that Robert Kirkman ever created these
are my buddies I think it'll be very
much like a like a Star Wars situation
where you meet a villain like you meet
like a Darth Vader which is like this
wolf guy here and then eventually you
meet the Emperor someone way worse just
to be clear though I don't think the
wolves have anything to do with the
saviors and I don't think we'll see any
of those people until they deal with the
Wolves first until they deal with the
aftermath of that then they find other
people like another community of people
a la hilltop then I then I think they'll
start rolling out like the next villain
after that which would be the Savior's
moving out to number three
none of the core cast members like main
cast members will be maimed in
significant ways Robert Kirkman has
always said that nothing is completely
off the table but as we've learned from
the show
like you you really don't get Maine's in
a huge way unless the show is getting
ready to kill you off like Tyrese like
if they were gonna chop someone's limb
off and it was gonna require a bunch of
extra makeup the actor would have to
spend an extra couple hours every day in
a makeup chair that's why I think like
up-and-comer Chandler Riggs here
probably not gonna get maimed I think
the show's really trying to develop him
and like as he you know is like learning
to be a better actor I don't think
they're gonna try and make his job more
difficult than it needs to be that
doesn't mean that he's completely safe
from from an emotional perspective eated
could totally cut his heart out
metaphorically daryl is actually a
really good example of this too so like
they spent all this money to build him
this custom motorcycle they're probably
not gonna like chop his hands or feet up
so that he wouldn't be able to use it I
think it's just one way that the show is
keeping things as simple as possible
from a production standpoint and and
from a writing standpoint like they
don't have to write around missing limbs
moving that's number two
Jon Hamm will probably not play negan I
know it's a long way off but everyone
got like really excited when Jon Hamm
was like yeah I would totally love to
play negan that'd be great
the problem is is that Jon Hamm just
finished madman and he is like an
in-demand leading film actor which means
he's super busy and he's super expensive
comparatively to the other actors in the
show negan is like the biggest villain
Robert Kirkman ever created so when he
does come on the show he'll probably
stick around even longer than the
governor did which means like a huge
time commitment for an actor so I just I
don't think that Jon Hamm would be able
to fit all those weeks in between the
films that he's making there's actually
this really interesting story Jon Hamm
actually tried to get out of his Mad Men
contract during season seven you know
like they they broke the seasons up he
wanted to be in David Fincher's gone
girl film he was gonna play the Ben
Affleck character Matthew whiner
showrunner on Mad Men would not let him
out of his contract Morgan's like the
opposite example that he only appeared
in like brief scenes at like three
points during season five Lennie James
could have totally gone and like made a
film and then come back and done those
scenes but like I said negan
when he comes on he's probably gonna
come on in a big way like he's not just
gonna show up once and then never come
back for like six or eight episodes
whenever they do find the person that's
going to play negan I don't think
they'll announce it I think they'll try
to keep that as secret as possible like
they'll give him some other name even
Alexandra Breckenridge's character the
Jessie character they cast her
as a different name so like whenever she
was cast she had some fictitious name
and my number one prediction for season
six Rick and Carl will both be safe this
might sound a little strange but the
biggest surprise I think on Walking Dead
this year wasn't the people that died it
was the people that did not die it's
like the show is going out of its way to
keep as many of the main cast members
around as long as possible
understandably it's like the most
popular show in the world you know
people are familiar with these certain
characters so I think they tried to
introduce changes as organically and as
slowly as possible like they just want
to take a dramatic left turn and just
alienate like half their audience
seriously now that madman is gone
Walking Dead is probably like 75% of
AMC's revenue that means it is like the
most closely-guarded asset as is are
like their most popular characters so
here's my really big question for you
guys do you think that AMC would ever
have the balls to kill off Daryl or Rick
Grimes like their two most popular
characters I definitely expect the show
to go into season seven after that you
know who knows
I think they'll try to keep it around as
long as possible the main show but they
got the spin-off show developing so I
think if things go well with that then
they'll slowly start cycling main actors
out of the main show so I think it might
be like season 8 before Rick Grimes sits
the chopping block Daryl Dixon I think
is an even more popular character so I
think he'll outlast Rick Grimes but
that's all just speculation sometimes
like an actor will leave a show because
they have a bigger opportunity so that
can change the story in ways that
writers hadn't planned on changing it so
in related news but I'm probably in ado
for my next Walking Dead bonus videos do
like a morgan video like I did for Daryl
Michonne and Rick Grimes be sure to
subscribe to get that if there's any
specific bonus videos you guys want just
just leave me requests in the comments
and don't forget Game of Thrones
premiering this Sunday I don't know how
many of you guys are or Game of Thrones
fans but it is like the perfect antidote
to Phil the walking dead shape hole in
your heart I'm gonna be doing all kinds
of special giveaways for it it'll run
for 10 episodes it's gonna start this
Sunday even if you don't get HBO you can
get the HBO now service for $15 so you
can watch Game of Thrones and then
cancel it after you're done there's also
some more cool updates from WonderCon so
I'm gonna try and get the WonderCon
related stuff out by Tuesday so while
you guys wait for all that stuff to drop
you can click here for my latest Game of
Thrones Season 5 video remember coming
Sunday and you can click here for all my
Walking Dead Season 5 videos thank you
so much for watching let's all have I'll
see you guys tonight